so our sing tough this morning
hi can you hear me I would like to start
by thanking the organizers for inviting
me to speak here it's a great honor and
I'm very happy to to be here so let me
start by introducing the main characters
in in my talk X would be hyperbolic
riemann surface finite type which simply
means that we can write X as a
difference of X bar minus a finite set
of points and make the bars are closed
and has genus G and I usually think of a
well
a riemann surface to look like that
hyperbolic means that the universal
cover of this riemann surface is simply
the unit disc and very concretely we can
always express X of the quotient of the
unit disk by a discrete group over the
morphisms which acts properly this
continuously on the disk so that the
unit is also equipped with a natural
like aromatic of constant curvature
minus four and I will denote the unit is
with this metric in this dog as well
using the impatient ch1 for the complex
hyperbolic line and of course the
riemann surface me hates natural
complete metric of constant curvature
since the morsel group in this case
coincides with a orientation preserving
a summit is of ch1 and being finite type
can also it's also given with the saying
that X is a finite volume okay so the
collection of all these Riemann surfaces
from the moduli space there are more
fission classes
I was warned I should write big good and
the modular spaces are known to be
complex quasi-projective variety and let
me introduce tight cooler space as the
universal cover of model a space
so type Mueller space is again naturally
a complex manifold of complicated I
mentioned three G minus three plus M and
remarkable well welcome to theorem of
birth says that tycoon space can be
realized that the simplest type of a
complex manifold is simply bount it's
contractable domain in a complex vector
space or the same dimension
and not like the human services
themselves modular space can be
presented as a quotient this bounded
domain by a discrete group of fertile
morphisms
well realize immortalized space as a
complex orbital or finite volume for a
natural metrical techno space which I
will be talking about shortly so this is
analogous to a more classical situation
and that is the situation of well that's
the case of locally symmetric varieties
of non compact type or equivalently
locally her missing somatic manifold and
they can always be presented as a
quotient of a bondage somatic domain by
a discrete group of automorphisms
so let me remind you what about its
method the main means I will give a
complex analytical definition it simply
says that about every point there is a
flip there is a holomorphic involution
but for any point there exist a
holomorphic involution that's at this
point is an isolated fixed point
and of course a class of is bonded smack
domains coincides with a with a class of
a hermitian symmetric spaces but I would
like to view them as bounty domains as
complex bounty domains for this talk and
forget the hermitian metric so a
consequence of this definition which
might not be clear immediately is that
the automorphism group is very large
attack transitively one points in
directions and well the theme of trying
to defend analogies between this class
of well symmetric spaces and techno
space has been a major driving force in
attacking Earth theory I won't say too
much about it but I want to mention two
important things one is that the
simplest case when the dimension of
titanum space is 1 then in fact they
coincide so techno space is simply the
unit disk by holomorphic to the unit
disk which again simply the complex
parabolic line so it is a bounded
somatic domain also let me not use a
notation BSD to save my life
however the dimension is bigger than to
begin than or equal to 2 and the
automorphism group of Thai communal
space is discrete so this is the result
you do Royden
this in the case when we have no
punctures and moreover there is no point
about which techno space is symmetric so
there's no settlement information for
any point so it is very different
globally from being a symmetric space
android UNS idea for proving this result
i will study the kobayashi metric the
intrinsically asthmatic on one bound
domain so and this is what i would like
to do in this talk as well so let me
introduce the intrinsic about ya somatic
informally that says that any bounty
domain is equipped with an intrinsic
geometric shape so let Omega be some
bounty domain
then the intrinsic made the kobayashi
metric is simply the largest metric with
the property that all follow morphic
maps from the unit disco or equivalent
from stage one into this domain they are
non expanding and let me just point out
that this determines a norm on the
tangent space that is a finnstrom metric
but also a distance function on pressure
points and let me understand what is the
fundamental property of this metric
is that all [ __ ] morphic maps between
domains are always non expanding in the
cosmetics
so this is just an analogue this is just
a trivial consequence of the definition
is an analogue of this verse lemma for
bounty domains name dimension so before
doing anything else let me just give you
some examples of what the cosmetic looks
like so in the case of the unit ball the
unit round ball the Kobayashi metric is
simply the complex hyperbolic metric so
it is a killer metric has constant
curvature holomorphic image curvature
and coincides with a with a limiter
mission with symmetric metric under
space but this is essentially the only
case where the cosmetic will be Romanian
so well a particular example of that is
when N equals 1 when we just have a unit
disk
another example is the by this the
product of 250 beast in this case the
Kobayashi metric is is the soup metric
of the two factors so in particular here
it is not a minute it's not reminding
anymore and the last example which is a
Detroit then it says that the Kobayashi
Matt you can type in the space coincides
with the Titan dramatic and this is a
fantastic result because the type mera
metric is well is accessible you
understand dramatically its properties
so I haven't yet introduced what attack
Merman Turkey so let me just do it now
so for any point in that new space
responding to Samba Lima surface X there
is a natural identification between the
cotangent space to tighten the space
over that point with the complex vector
space of calamari quadratic integrable
holomorphic quadratic differentials on X
these are holomorphic forms of the form
some local coordinate Z and well this
vector space is equipped with the
national norm it has an l1 norm given by
integrating
this quadratic differential of the
dairyman surface and the type mimetic is
the geometric so it is a fin symmetric
given by that you all did your norm on
tangent spaces okay so
so let me tell you what I consider to be
an amazing fact although the title or
metric of the Kobayashi metric on tight
misplaced and bonded symmetric domains
is practically never hermitian these
spaces are abundantly populated by
holomorphic complex hyperbolic lines so
let Amiga be tighten in space or BSD
then for any points in Direction there
exist a holomorphic map passing through
this point and in that direction which
is a which is a totally disguise summary
meaning that it locally preserves
distance of points or it sends limited a
sixteen-year in genetics and in the case
of type Miller space this total
exhilaration summit is their contact
mode tighten your discs and they are
related they arise from a natural from
the natural to our action on the bundle
of quadratic differentials so a falker
problem in this was indictment for a
while was whether being a totally dark
isometry is enough to guarantee that you
are Titan a disc that is it's a
holomorphic a totally disguise symmetry
and the first term I would like to state
settle this question this problem
sorry so let F be a totally geodesic
isometry
for the cosmetics so I will I will keep
this word I would always refer to the
Cabela's matter you can take away
somebody's well then in fact f is
holomorphic or anti holomorphic
and in particular it is a type of disc
and the assumptions on live here very
weak all I know is it's an isometry I
don't start with any other assumption
even being sensible so all I know is
that it preserves the sense of coins so
let me make one remark that this is
known to be true if we replace that
inner space with a bounded symmetric
domain of Rank 1 which is just a complex
hyperbolic spaces
however it fails in highly-ranked so
it's false if if the Rangoon is - and
has to do with the Supreme o matic on
the product was too biased essentially
so in fact the theory of my previous it
holds for a fairly large class of bounty
domains including C to want some techno
spaces I hope this gets the prefer later
ok so that settles what happens in
dimension one so the next question is
what happens when the dimension of the
dimensions are at least two
and willing to start by noting that
there are many holomorphic isometries
between well from now on I will just
stick to considering how Mordecai
geometries so it is known that there are
in fact many holomorphic isometries
between bounded semantic domains and
tighter spaces
and that for any bounded symmetric
domain and a meet item on a space you
can always find well as many as you like
other banks many domains with one or
more fication metric maps like that
however the the next results I will
state so that when a dimension is at
least two bonnets megadome a nice and
tight no spaces they do not mix at all
in their Kobayashi metric
so particular there is no holomorphic
isometry from a bounded symmetric domain
into techno space or from techno space
to Bonnie's making domain and here by a
holomorphic isometry I don't require F
to be totally geodesic all I want is to
preserve the norm
okay so let me just state has a super
theorem special case of that which I
think it's already interesting I'm Joan
there is no holomorphic isometry from
ch2 in to techno space
and we also proved a similar theorem for
asymmetric submarines so let me say that
well if Omega and D G n R as in theorem
2 then there is no
holomorphic isometric submersion
between bounded semantic domains and
technical spaces and by holomorphic a
semantic submersion I mean a holomorphic
map such that the dual of the
differential is an isometry for for the
dual norms
so let me make several remarks three
it is known that there exist many
holomorphic are there exist item lockers
there are many Titan occurs in modular
space and by technical I mean
isometrically merged heavy volcano
surface a finite type or
and the existence of such curves hello
has a lot of applications with your
beards so one of the main motivations
for proving theorem 2 is the following
immediate corollary that says that there
are no higher dimensional analogues
those high dimensional local isometric
varieties isometrically immersed in mg
in the particular no complex hyperbolic
ax varieties so the secondary market
wanna make is well there exist or a
morphic now from tightness pages into
bonded somatic domains so the simplest
one is the Torelli mob that sensor image
surfaced it's a Cobian and it's a
holomorphic map into the single space
which is a bonded somatic domain this
mouse are known to be strictly
contracting in most directions and the
third remark has to do with fear and 3
in fact there are a lot more fake
isometric submergence of tightness space
on to the converse hyperbolic land and
they are given by holomorphic
retractions onto a building technologies
so in particular that shows that the
restriction of the dimensions are
necessary for that result ok
so for any a billion Tecna disk an
attack medic generated by the square of
holomorphic one for the regressor
holomorphic reaction of Tecna space onto
this disk and they're given by
normalized periods alternatively there
are some directions where the Torelli
mob is isometric and these are these are
exactly these a billion directions and
projections column or projections exist
for bondage make domains so what I would
like to do for the remaining of the talk
is try to sketch the ideas I'll try to
focus on theorem 1 and theorem 2 Prime
and try to sketch the ideas and if I
have any time remaining I would also
want to mention a few open problems in
this direction
so although technically the proofs for
theorem 1 and theorem 2 primer very
different they both use one common idea
which is that of complexification in
real education that isn't the first
theorem will try to complexify and 2
prime will try to do the opposite so let
me just describe an instance of that in
the study of tycoon ad geodesics which
will be important in the proof so let me
recall it for any quadratic differential
referred there is a tight mirror disk
that's a holomorphic isometry from CH
wanted to take my space which arises
from his natural self to our action and
very clearly the quadric differential
allows us to express this riemann
surface as a finite polygon in the plane
with pairs of parallel sides identified
by symmetries and then the linear action
result on the plane just acts on these
polygons
but for any quadratic differential there
is a another interesting geometric
invariant which is the a pair of
transverse major affiliations on the
riemann surface and concretely in a
coordinate chart with the quadratic
differential take this form this is just
simply the measure foliation given by
vertical lines in the plane and the
transverse measure is simply the total
variation in the x direction so you can
just pull back the complex while the
vertical lines to the surface and get a
measure affiliation and it will have
singularities of the zeros of the
quadratic Forenza but otherwise it's a
it's an exfoliation so in particular
this map is known to give an embedding
of this bundle of quadrant differentials
inside the product of the space of
measured foliation
after the equivalence relation that is
you'd like to identify two when they
differ by a nice sort of preserving the
transverse measures or by splitting as
ears and moreover well this base has
natural continues function the geometric
intersection pairing
which generalizes the geometric
intersection of simple closed curves and
it encodes the type molar metric via
this mass formula
and whereas this complex type disk arise
from yourself to action here we only see
the real structure so we lose of
information we had about complex
diuretics and
that gives us two distinct ways of
understanding technology agnostic so the
first one coming from the let me first
start given any unit geodesic there are
two ways you can describe it one is via
digital to our action with the absolute
that is that there is an extension there
is a complexification which is
holomorphic in totally geodesic and has
described very concretely in terms of
this a subtraction and the other way is
in terms of measure foliation x' and in
this case there is a lift while the
canonical lift
simply given is described by very simple
form in terms of the symbol which
provides a very convenient way of
understanding the the real Jurassic okay
so both of these will what descriptions
will take part in the proofs of the
hearings so let me just start by trying
to explain that
so in the first case we start with the
totally genetic isometry in the retinal
space so in particular that means that
any geodesic here will have to tighten a
geodesic and this tycoon's geodesic
extends the holomorphic isometry of ch1
inside techno space so the idea is to
try to organize all these technologies
into a new map
so in particular we would like to forget
the complex structure here we embedded
as a totally real diagonal inside this
by disk and then the first step in the
proof is that we extend half using the
tightener disks to a map on these bodies
and how does this work
well for any geodesic any real geodesic
will ch1 there exists a holomorphic
complexification inside this by disk and
then we define F on this CH 1 to be the
diagonal disk and the important point
here is that these complexification as
gamma runs over all geodesics in ch1
they foliate this by disk at least the
complement of this totally real diagonal
okay so now having a well-defined map
the second step of the process to
produce maps holomorphic and that's
certainly not obvious think a priori F
need not even be differentiable analytic
that is it was a complex analysis so I
will not talk but what do we get once we
know that f is holomorphic well then we
have a holomorphic family of disks and
what what we we prove assuming that this
F was totally geodesic
so let me just denote the by disc as a
square they released a slice which is
either horizontal or vertical such that
F restricted on this slice is unbounded
along a positive set of radial aids and
let me just note something well these
slices are of course not totally drastic
right so for any geodesic here it
complexified to give you holomorphic map
from ch1 inside here and that's simply
given by the graph of the reflection if
you like with respect to the geodesic
any geodesic is a reflection and then
graph of this reflection is the
holomorphic extension of the real to
daesik here and then on this lies i just
defined them up to be the techno disk
and the reason this is all the fine is
because all these I mean this this will
intersect along a subtle real diagonal
but because we have a well-defined map
to begin with these contractions leaves
a well-defined map another way to think
about that if if this map if the image
of this map was not a tightener disc it
would have to be some totally really
symmetric plane tightness space and then
in sort of type Mali disc intersected
everywhere and then what this map does
organizes this into a holomorphic map ok
so the horizontal and vertical slices
here are not F does not restrict to an
isometry it's not clear well in
principle why this should be true and
indeed the fact that F is totally
realistic it's very important in proving
that but once we know that then we are
done because we don't just have one
slice we have a whole family of slices
but then this particular holomorphic
discs well the radio layer is almost all
of them will converge total degenerate
points in the boundary of of the burst
embedding and Sullivans theorem says
that these are rigid you can move on so
it follows by Sullivan's rigidity
theorem that
every stricken - no parallel slices is
is equal to this well F agrees on all
the spiral slices
which is essentially what we wanted to
prove because this is a holomorphic map
and it's totally generate the image is
diagonally disc or just because of the
existence of Technol discs it's a
totally real that yeah diagonal
embedding so I take the opposite complex
structure here so that the graphs are
holomorphic
well we have this product structure and
then we have this holomorphic slices the
vertical and horizontal ones and I claim
that either sound vertical or some
horizontal one have the property that
when F is restricted on them it is
unbounded along a set of positive
measure along a set of radial range of
positive measure now this raise that's
non-trivial
in fact it has to do with the fact that
you do with the fact that just right
over here the point Z comma W lives on a
complexification of a geodesic if and
only if the point W comma Z lies on this
complication so it's a trivial fact but
actually this is exactly what is hidden
behind this proof the reason is because
the distance between this pork these two
points in the cosmetic of the product is
going to be equal to the attack made
distance between Z and W so you know
that that's supposed to be sketch is
holomorphic here which means if you
change the complex structure is called a
morph again and holomorphic which is
exactly where this either-or
sorry yes
so did I ask the question
oh how do you talk morally but it is
afterwards so let me just state the the
proof of to prime there we start with a
holomorphic map from th to in to techno
space the holomorphic isometry the idea
to do the opposite to restrict this map
to a totally real so we strict totally
and totally geodesic okay that that step
is easy you can do that but why do we
get from that let me do a picture so
this is the image of this totally real
hyperbolic plane in Titan space which is
a totally realistic subset of techno
space
and I considered two orthogonal genetics
generated by quadratic differentials
extra mu P and a Riemann surface and X
comma Q then the idea is to explore what
to exploit but to use the asymptotic
behavior of the geodesics to relate the
complex hyperbolic horror cycles to
level set of extreme lengths
and the reason we can do that is due to
theorem of measure saying that once
these are chosen to be generic enough
for example the vertical foliation of
both quadratic differentials are
uniquely ergodic and minimal then then
there is a well then this this method
works and indeed one can describe this
complex hyperbolic horror cycles as
being level sets of extrema length for
the corresponding measure affiliations
so the absurd of this discussion is that
we we have a very nice description
geometric description of the geometric
intersection pairing between these two
measure foliation which is simply given
by this formula it described in terms of
the distance of these two points
so what we do next is just stop wearing
this totally real slice so we very so
that it contains well we can fix one of
the geodesics and we there in your fog
another one inside the Tecna disk then
because of the symmetries because this
this can be realized by holomorphic map
of states too it follows that this
distance doesn't change
so in particular consequence of that
is that the geometric intersection
pairing between these two foliation does
not depend on the angle it's independent
and we conclude the proof by proving
that this is impossible by direct
geometric get a contradiction by the
geometric argument on the riemann
surface we prove that this this
expression is never independent of the
angle in fact it is given by the
following formula
so it is never independent of the angle
and that's where the contradiction come
from okay so that was a brief sketch of
the of the priest are there any
questions
okay so the remaining five minutes I
would like to briefly mention some open
questions but I would like to know the
answer and that would be interesting too
the first one is the bottom one is this
theorem well is every isometry c1 and
somebody and by astrometry having a
local isometry for the Kobayashi norms
is it the type of disc the problem is
that such a magnet will not insure him
up to - the geodesics so this argument
doesn't apply because there's no good
way of extending so a second question is
the proof of theorem to use the global
geometry of techno space it will be an
interesting challenge to try to find
anything decimal proof so is there a
local isometry their linear asymmetry
from the complex to plane with the round
metric
the dancing space over a riemann surface
with respect to the kobayashi music and
let me just mention here the theorem
that there are no linear isometries on
the dual matrix on the quadratic
differentials with a with the l1 norm
and what what this question asked is
whether one can actually find a
symmetric submergence well from this
base on to this and this is a an
essential ingredient in the proof of
theorem three so let me mention one
third question which is a geometric
version of this is there a holomorphic
map from a hermitian manifold
there is an isometry for the Nerds it's
a local SMD again positive indication
for that so the corollary of of the RM -
is that the answer is no if this system
to be Kaler with either holomorphic
curvature think about below by minus 4
or f seem to be totally geodesic however
in general I don't know the answer
let me just mention one last problem and
that is s theorem to - for infinite
dimensional bounded smelly domains
probably the most interesting out of the
four
so this is equivalent to asking for
during an attack unit disk is their
holomorphic rejection on this Ahmed disk
and the yet another equivalent way to
ask is what are the characters or emetic
coincides with trouble a symmetric